a new report by the advocacy group glaad
says 84 percent of lgbtq adults feel
there are not enough protections on
social media to prevent discrimination
and harassment the report says five
major social media giants failed when it
comes to things like restricting harmful
content and offering gender pronoun
options on profiles cbs news has reached
out to all five social media platforms
meta on behalf of instagram and facebook
says they prohibit violent dehumanizing
content directed against people who
identify as lgbtq plus tick tock says
they continuously take steps to
strengthen protections for marginalized
people and communities twitter says they
welcome glad's feedback and the
opportunity to better understand the
experiences and needs of lgbtq plus
communities youtube has not responded
glad president and ceo sarah kate ellis
joins us first on cbs mornings good
morning thank you for bringing attention
to this you know when we were reading
about this um i was shocked that one out
of four lgbtq youth has attempted
suicide in the last year yeah and this
social media environment is contributing
to that what what can parents do what
can allies do to fight this yeah um so
the environment out there right now is
really tough for lgbtq people especially
our youth that's a cdc number so just to
give you an idea the also what's
happened this past year is that we've
seen over 300 anti-lgbtq
bills at the state level proposed this
is all driven
from online that's where people get
together that's where this hate and
discrimination festers so there's a few
things that people can do one first and
foremost is unfortunately and this is
why we're doing the report it's on us
it's on parents it's on kids it's on
advocacy groups to report it to these
big companies and they all have
reporting mechanisms number two is i
always say that allies should share
positive content the joy for queer
people for lgbtq plus people but also
really important like i said is to
report it as well you know sarah every
one of these five major social media
companies that you spotlight in the
report are glad spotlights uh they all
have policies of protection and
inclusion and yet all of them have
failing grades in the report so where's
the disconnect
that's a great question the big
disconnect here is that they do have
policy they don't have enforcement so
it's the wild wild west you can say one
thing but a whole other thing is
actually happening online we just saw it
last week with elliot page who was
targeted online and her dead his dead
name was used and you know videos were
surfaced and created and targeted at him
and so we had to get in touch with them
elliot page's team had to get in touch
with them to stop it or to curb it and
we know they have the tools we've seen
them use the tools to stop it and get
ahead of it but instead it's all on us
um the people who are on those platforms
and the advocacy groups to report it and
to try and get them to stop it and
that's why we did the report in the
first place was to get them to get ahead
of this and not come up from behind what
what are the tools yeah i was going to
say you have the tools they or you say
they have the tools but they're not
using them or are they doing anything
right i guess well i think we saw it and
there's been a lot of reporting on it in
the 2020 election when all this
misinformation was slowed down or
stopped before the election and then it
was rebooted after and it was allowed to
go forward after this is clearly profit
over people so some of the tools are
friction they can slow down the spread
of misinformation they can actually stop
it too the spread of misinformation and
they can see things that are starting to
bubble and stop them or divert them
based on the tools that they have at
their disability very tricky thing
though is that one person's
misinformation is another person's free
speech and it's hard to know who to
empower to oversee or police that
congress the tech platforms us what do
you think well i think this is about
safety first and foremost because what
we're seeing again where we started is
that this turns into real world
challenges and problems the 31 white
supremacists who were planning on
turning up for a peaceful gay pride
event or lgbtq event a couple of weeks
ago during pride month that started
online so we have to be really careful
and we do need government intervention
here and we need the right policies this
has been going on over a decade now and
we haven't you know congress has been
really
you know
not ineffective to say the best
um here and we're not comprehensive
legislation at all not at all and we
need to start seeing things move forward
here
all right sarah k ellis uh ceo of glad
thank you very much for being here uh
and the report social media safety index
is out now thanks for having me